Let me tell you if you think because we're Christians, and I'm holding this cross that you could come here
You can lie in our faces, and then you can attack our people *crowd roars*
Man 1: He said he's not an Islamic scholar..
Ali: I'm not an Islamic scholar..
You're a Quranic scholar aren't you?
Ali: No.
You're a Bible scholar?
Ali: Nononononono..
(Erratic laughter)
Ali: I just wanted to have a little discussion..
We got a lot of friends with Kurds.
No, not recorded though.
What's it bout?
Ali: Just basically general. For example, I just heard your talk.
Ali: ..and as a Muslim. I'm British myself, and you talked about..uh..those Muslim..gangs..
Ali: We know that and we know that's been on the news and personally myself as a British Muslim everything you said there..
Ali: Not everything, I'd say about 20-25% of stuff I agree with because the thing is my question here is to you is..
Sorry, give me one second..
Ali: Okay, okay.. You can call her as well cuz I really want to talk to Jada as well.
Ali: I just want to have a conversation..
Ali: Hi Jada, how you doin?
Jada: I'm good, hey how're you?
Ali: Yeah, I'm good.
Ali: I just wonderin..
Ali: If we can have a little discussion..
Ali: I just came here.. I'm not here to cause any trouble.
Jada: I was just goin to shake your hand but you're not allowed to shake my hand, are you?
Ali: Yeah, out of respect.
Ali: Out of respect.. Out of res pect..
Jada: What do you mean?
Ali: For example, The Queen.
Ali: Not even everybody can shake The Queen's hand.
Ali: Can't, well it's just a shake of the hand. But I don't want to, actually.
Jada: But why don't you want to shake my hand?
Ali: If you would just respect that please?
Jada: It's customary to meet someone and shake their hand.
Jada: Am I dirty? Or is it because I'm kuffar? (an unbeliever)
Jada: Because I'm kuffar?
Jada: Can I ask?
Jada: Does that have anything to do with your prophet saying that women are deficient in intelligence? Or deficient in religion?
Ali: No, not really..
Jada: No? I'm just considered unclean?
Ali: No, no Jada.. No Jada..
Jada: No??
Ali: A lot of Muslims... The first University was built by a Muslim woman.
Ali: Education is KEY for Muslim women.
Ali: I came here today to say, about what you said most.. Some of the stuff I agree. How?
Ali: What I wanted to say is, look as a Muslim. I'm British. I'm Kurdish. Yeah. Okay..
Ali: Now, you talked about grooming gangs.
Yeah. For example.. I don't..
(Jada cuts off..) Jada: Muslim grooming gangs.
Ali: I don't give a damn if they're Muslim, non-Muslim..
Ali: If if you guys said we're gonna go after all grooming gangs, besides if they're Muslim or non-Muslim..
Ali: I'll be right behind you guys.
Ali: If you want to go after terrorists. I will go after.. Lemme tell you something..
Ali: One of my mates, Musa, he's in a video of ISIS.
Ali: ..and they want to behead him. Yeah? He's in the video.
Ali: ISIS is our enemy as much as they are yours.
Jada: D'you know wot the fact is though?
Jada: The fact is~ That you're talking about grooming gangs..
Jada: Talking about non-Muslim grooming gangs..
Jada: You're talking about non-Muslim terrorists..
Jada: Point them out to me..
Ali: And Muslims..and Muslims..
Jada: Point.. Point them out to me..
Ali: Oh yeah, sure..
Jada: Becauuuse~ Because, because..
Jada: Hold on a minute, hold on a minute..
Jada: Point them out to me in this country.
Jada: I've seen one, hold on, I've seen one non-Muslim terror attack..
Ali: Okay..
Jada: ..which was reactive. It was that silly bugger that drove into those people of the mosque.
Jada: Innocent Muslims.
Jada: Don't.. I don't condone that. It's absolutely disgraceful. Alright?
Jada: But that's one, one..act.. A reaction..toooo..
Jada: Children being scraped off the wall of Manchester Arena. Right? Not making it right..
Jada: It's disgusting act.
Ali: Yeah. Okay..
Jada: You point out to me..
Jada: ..where are, the Sikh grooming gangs?
Jada: Where are the Hindu grooming gangs?
Jada: Where are the.. Atheist grooming gangs?
Jada: Where are they?
Jada: The epidemic comes from the scriptures. From your prophet..
Ali: Look..
Jada: ..which says that the kuffar..
Jada: Allah said that the kuffar can be taken. The kuffar women and children could be taken as sex slave.
Ali: That's not the truth.
Jada: That is true.
Jada: That IS true.
Jada: Are we go get into taqiyya? (Telling a lie to save/protect oneself)
Ali: Taqiyya is Shia's. I'm more of a Sunni.
Ali: Shia do taqiyya. I don't.
Jada: Okay..
Jada: But you read the same book?
Ali: Yes. But..
Jada: You read the same book?
Ali: Yes, but.. In the book nowhere does it say, do taqiyya.
Jada: Well.. Hold, hold on a minute..
Jada: Taqiyya is a principle.
Jada: What I'm saying is, the book and the hadiths..
Jada: They.. They expressly state..
Jada: ..that the Muslims are permitted to take the non-Muslim, kuffar..
Jada: ..women and children as sex slaves,
Jada: ..as an act of jihad.
Ali: No. No.
Jada: Yes it does. Yes it does.
Ali: Can I, can I, can I..
Jada: Let's not..
Ali: Taqiyya's done by Shias. I'm not a Shia.
Jada: You read the same book..
Ali: Hear me out..
Jada: Yeah, yeah.. Go on.
Ali: Thank you Jada. Thank you.
Ali: I heard you out.
Ali: I understand..
Ali: I understand every single one of you guys is concerned, yeah..
Ali: You see terrorists attack..
Ali: Yes, a lot of those have been Muslims.
Ali: My, my issue is this.. Can you show me a single verse in the Quran, the hadith, and the Islamic literature..
Ali: Where it says, "Go..and kill..innocent people."?
Jada: Yes I can. Yes I can.
Jada: Yes I can. Do you want to hear it?
Ali: Yes. Yes.
Jada: "I will cast terror into the hearts of the disbelievers, therefore cut off their necks, and cut off every fingertip of them.."
Jada: That's ONE!
Ali: Okay that's one..
Jada: That's one..
Ali: Okay..
Jada: There are hundred and forty two..
Jada: Go to surah 5, got to surah 8, go to surah 12..
Jada: They're in there..
Jada: Don't come here and pretend to me that your book is any different than any other sect of Islam.
Jada: I've studied the Quran..
Jada: I've studied the Bible.. Let me tell you one thing..
Ali: Yeah.
Jada: ..and this is a fact..
Jada: If you follow the Quran..to the letter..
Jada: You are obliged..
Ali: I do. I do.
Jada: No you don't..
Jada: No you don't.
Ali: I follow it to the letter.
Jada: How many people..
Jada: How many kuffar have you killed?
Ali: THAT'S THE POINT..
Jada: How many kuffar have you killed??
Ali: The Quran doesn't teach that.
Jada: Yes it does.
Ali: IT DOES NOT.
Jada: Don't.. Don't make a pratt out've yourself darling.
Jada: It just started to look really silly.
Ali: Can I clarify? Can I clarify?
Jada: Let me clarify, right.. Let me clarify..
Jada: You started to look really silly..
Jada: If youd've come to me and said to me,
Jada: ..there are verses in the Quran that say, "kill the kuffar,"..and I don't agree with them..
Jada: ..I'd've said to you, "Fair play!"
Jada: You're probably not a Muslim.. You're an apostate. But you haven't said that.
Jada: What you've said to me is, "I'm a DEVOUT Muslim..
Ali: Yes.
Jada:..and that it doesn't say that in the Quran."?
Jada: Don't come over here and tryin' to mug off (lie to) people which have read your scriptures right?
Ali: Show me where it says,
Ali: "Go and kill.."
Jada: In surah 5.
Ali: Let's quote surah 5 yeah?
Jada: "I will cast terror into the heart of the disbelievers..
Ali: WHICH disbelievers?
Ali: Jada, there's 2 types of kuffar, yeah?
Jada: Hold on.
Jada: Can I have.. Just before you say this..
Jada: Can I have a show of hands, who's an Atheist here?
Jada: Cuz what he's about to do~
Jada: ..is he's about to say, "The people of the book, as in myself, the Christians, and the Jews~..
Jada: ..they're not real kuffar."
Jada: But if any of you are Atheists, this man is about to say that..
Jada: ..YOU'RE the ones he should behead.
Jada: Go on, do it!
Jada: Cuz I know what you're gonna say..
Ali: Can I.. Can I speak?
Ali: Paul! Please come closer. You're too far away..
Ali: There's 3 types..
Ali: There's.. There's 2 types of non-Muslims.
Ali: They are the ones who are combatant, and there's the ones that are not combative.
Ali: So for example, if I'm a Muslim..
Jada: Let me tell you~
Jada: EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE NON-MUSLIMS HERE~~!
Jada: ARE COMBATANT! AND YOU CAN RELY ON THAT SON!
Jada: You can rely on that..
Ali: Can I finish?
Ali: Jada, my point is this, if I am coming..
Ali: Or let's suppose Hitler and Nazis are coming to Britain to attack us..
Ali: ..we as the British people have to help our..
Ali: ..country and fight them off!
Ali: That is not the same as us going to innocent Germans and say,
Ali: "Hey! Um gonna kill you! Why?! Because I feel that.."
Jada: Alright. Okay~
Ali: So please don't carry out (???)..
Ali: This is my religion.
Jada: So.. You want to draw the parallel of Nazism?
Jada: I'd LOVE to do this!
Jada: I LOVE IT!
Jada: Right, you tell me then.. yeah?
Jada: There are Nazi, who've put in people in concentration camps..
Jada: There are Nazi who shoot people in the head.. Innocent people.
Ali: And Jews.. 6 million Jews were.. wiped.
Jada: Then, there were people~
Jada: ..that..
Jada: Align themselves with the Nazi party.
Jada: The BELIEVES~..
Jada: ..everyfing the Nazi party stood for..
Jada: ..but they didn't do it themselves.
Jada: Are they just as bad?
Ali: Okay, yes.
Jada: Okay..
Jada: They are just as bad.. Okay..
Jada: Let me tell you..what YOU have just admitted..
Jada: You've just admitted that, there are Muslims..
Ali: Yes..
Jada: ..that support Islam..
Jada: ..and SUPPORT..
Jada: ..the.. Islamic terrorists, and SUPPORT the atrocities..
Jada: That are DICTATED and INSTRUCTED..
Jada: ..in the Quran.. Right.. Hold on, hold on..
Jada: You're saying and the people that follow the ideology of Islam..
Jada: You've just said, "Those who follow the Nazi ideology.."
Jada: "..are as bad as the Nazis killing."
Jada: The Muslims following Islam as an ideology..
Jada: ..are as bad as the Muslims killing because it's IN THE BOOK.
Jada: Yes it is!
Jada: Do you know what you need to do?
Jada: You need to.. accept Jesus into your heart.
Ali: I already have..
Jada: You need to turn away~
Jada: From this BARBARISM.. This barbarism.
Jada: This barbaric ideology..
Jada: That you quite clearly say.. That you stand for wholeheartedly..
Jada: If you DO, then the BLOOD of every innocent child from Manchester Arena..
Jada: ..IS ON YOUR HANDS!
Jada: THE BLOOD OF EVERYBODY ON THE BRIDGES IS ON YOUR HANDS.
Jada: THE BLOOD OF EVERY SINGLE ..
Jada: ..INNOCENT PERSON IN EVERY SINGLE ISLAMIC TERROR ATTACK..
Jada: ..IS ON. YOUR. HANDS!
Jada: So do you what, sir~?!
Jada: I'm GLAD you refused to shake my hand.
Jada: Because there's NOTHING WORSE..
Jada: Than SOMEONE who STANDS for something..
Jada: ..but it's TOO WEAK to admit it.
Jada: Now let me tell you..
Jada: YOU SIR, ARE MY ENEMY!
Ali: I'm not your enemy..
Jada: Yes, YOU ARE!
Jada: You know what Jesus said?
Jada: Jesus Christ said..
(Crowd jeers and claps)
Jada: "I do not come in peace,
Jada: "..but I come with a sword, I come to turn mother against son, against father against son.."
Jada: "..mother against son-in-law."
Jada: Let me tell you,
Jada: IF YOU THINK..
Jada: ..THAT BECAUSE WE'RE CHRISTIANS,..
Jada: ..AND I'M HOLDING THIS CROSS..
Jada: THAT YOU COULD COME HERE..
Jada: ..YOU CAN LIE IN OUR FACES..
Jada: ..AND THEN YOU CAN ATTACK OUR PEOPLE..
Jada: THEN YOU LET YOUR PEOPLE KNOW..
Jada: ..THAT US CHRISTIANS..
Jada: ..ARE NOT TO BE MESSED WITH!
Jada: AND YOU'VE PICKED THE WRONG FIGHT!
Jada: Now I suggest you GO!
Jada: Off you go, sir!
Jada: There you've had your moment!
Ali: Why are you going?? Where're you going??
(Crowd chants) (GO! GO!) (STOP! STOP!)
Ali: Can I say something?
Ali: All she's done is PREACH..
Ali: ..and a group of people 've clapped.
Ali: You guys know very well, I'm not the enemy.
Ali: You know I'm not your enemy!
Ali: As you can see..
Ali: As you can see, when I came, clearly show them I said look..
Ali: ..can you show me a SINGLE verse in the Quran that says,
Ali: .."Go out and kill innocent people.."
Go be of crap and said bye. Bye. I'm going this is exactly the problem cuz she knows very well. She knows very well
Do you mind if I send this burger will come out of soap, it's gonna take a minute, okay?
Okay you hear okay, honest. I had obviously you can't say it there because that
Yeah, that's that's not problem
I just want to say something the reason why did you see?
They would clearly you will see them for example Jada and voting and their team they go to Muslim areas and they and they go
To Hungary much, and what they do is they go to these areas?
And they go to these ignorant Muslims who can't even speak English properly, okay?
Well, how do you respect and they talk yeah, and they know they can't do a reply?
But when somebody who knows this scripture a bit comes and challenges them what happens although all of a sudden
They say oh, we don't want to speak and then she gave a speech everybody clapped. I need to go now
This is exactly the problem because they know
Intellectually they have no next standard
And they know clearly nowhere in the Quran does it say go out there and kill innocent men women and children nowhere
So that's why what do they have to do. They have to cut us out because it
sabotages their whole objective
That's the reason why we came here today to show you guys and I knew this was gonna happen
I knew they'd never let me speak
She's gonna speak all over me and she knows for example one gonna say is gonna dismount in her ohh-ho claim
That's why look. How they just push this out exactly, but we're gonna each other try to get a conversation back with them
Hopefully okay, what happened?
Jayda what happened to our conversation
Oh come on my weapon David. I'm too busy come on man
Jada jada jada jada
Where's where's she going what happened to an international discussion why should run anyway?
Why should wanna go home? I know where you come from why is she running off from them jada jada
Jada
Jada why you know why do you want to speak to me you go to Muslim areas?
Why why you gonna pick what Muslims? You don't know their religion. I do. Why are you afraid to talk to me?
I voted come on Bodi. Can you show me a single verse in the Quran that says Goku innocent people?
You're cowards you guys are cowards you are cowards you caught me, but not Muslims
He won't be good Muslim that I know the religion I know my religion buddy run away
Jato guys when it comes to ignorant Muslims when it comes ignorant Muslims they don't they don't mind they don't mind
What
When it comes they're ignorant Muslims
They act it, but when it comes to people who don't know what they're talking about
They don't want to know they don't want to know what they're gonna know
So guys as you saw for yourself she came with hey shake my hand knowing very well as Muslims. We dog
She tried that didn't work. She came with your doing tequila. Nah. Sorry. I'm not sure didn't work
She came with your prophet this violence this that sorry didn't work
She came with uh, you're a Muslim if you're a Muslim
You should be coming how many memos? Did you kill sorry low blow? It didn't work
She came with a attitude aggressiveness shouting abuse. We are combatants. It didn't work. She wanted me to get aggressive
It didn't work
I asked unchallenged show me a single chapter in the entire Quran of the history of Islam
That says go kill innocent men women children or anyone. It didn't work. She couldn't show me one
She put all the verses all out of context and all those words are talking about the battle food when the enemy was attacking them
That's it. I'm back. They poor Golden Goose Jada as a scapegoat
Jaden use the security scapegoat, but not every day is gonna be like that day
We're going to eventually come and challenge you and expose you for how what you really are one little advance for me
It could look at this face because you're gonna be seeing a lot more of it be it Muslim or non-muslim. Hey bitches
we're gonna come after you ass British people be a Muslim or non-muslim are fed up of your heat vision of innocent people dying and
You will be challenged